DAN GALPIN: We introduced
Android Go edition last year
with the aim to bring the latest
Android improvements to more
entry level phone buyers.
There are now more than
200 Android Go devices
available in over 120 countries.
These devices are not only
popular in emerging markets,
such as India, and
Brazil, and Mexico,
but in the United
States as well.
With more than 100 manufacturers
planning to release devices
before the end of the
year, this is truly
a global opportunity for your
apps to reach a wider audience.
Fundamentally, the Android
Go edition experience
is based on three key pillars--
storage, delivering
twice the out of box data
storage compared to similarly
configured non-Go edition
Android devices;
data management,
helping users minimize
their data consumption
with features such as choosing
content quality in YouTube Go;
and security, offering the same
security features as Android 9,
such as Find My Device
and malware protection
with Google Play Protect.
Let's take a closer look
at how you can optimize
your apps for Android Go.
Start by targeting the
most recent Android API.
At the time of
publishing this video,
that's Android Pie API 28.
This enables you to gain benefit
such as improved memory use
while helping your apps run more
efficiently on devices with one
gigabyte of RAM or less.
There's a clear correlation
between lower app
size and higher install rates.
This is especially important
for Android Go edition users
as they have limited
storage capacity
and may incur
download data charges.
Therefore, keep your app under
40 megabytes and your game
under 65 megabytes.
The simplest and
most impactful thing
you can do to
reduce your app size
is to start using an
Android App Bundle.
Developers using
an App Bundle have
seen size savings of up to 65%.
This works because Google Play
uses your Android App Bundle
to build and serve APKs that
are optimized for each device
configuration.
This results in a smaller
app download for end users
by removing unused code
and resources needed
for other devices.
Additional optimizations you
can do to reduce your app size
are replace PNG or JPEG files
with HEIF or WebP assets.
For vector graphics,
use vector drawables.
Replace raw audio format
resources such as WAV
with MP3 or AAC resources.
Remove duplicate libraries
and, whenever possible,
focus on mobile-optimized
libraries.
Shrink and optimize your
unused code and resources
with tools such as ProGuard.
You can use the APK
analyzer in Android Studio
or from the command
line to help understand
how these optimizations
impact your APK size.
Another thing to check is your
app's Proportional Set Size,
or PSS.
Now this is your app's
physical memory footprint
that accounts for both shared
and unshared pages used
by your app.
You can easily check this using
ADB shell dumpsys meminfo.
Aim for PSS RAM usage
below 50 megabytes for apps
and below 150
megabytes for games.
And of course, make sure your
app functions without ANRs
and crashes by
testing and double
checking on Android Go
edition powered devices.
After making the optimizations,
it's time to publish.
Now one question
you might have is,
do I deliver the same
app to all my users
or specifically target an
optimized version of the app
to users of Android Go edition?
For most developers,
we recommend
publishing the same app
to all devices for those
who are using
Android and those who
are using Android Go addition.
By optimizing your app to run
well on Android Go edition
devices, all your users stand
to gain from the performance
benefits.
Another option is to publish
two separate apps, your existing
app and a light app that is
focused on Android Go edition
devices.
You can target certain
countries with a light app
or you can target all
devices in all locales.
It's up to you.
Now distributing a second
app isn't a decision
to be taken lightly.
You'll need to support and
maintain its code separately
and dedicate resources
to growing and engaging
a second audience alongside
your existing app.
As we mentioned at the
start of the video,
Android Go is a tremendous
opportunity for you
to grow your app
or game business.
To learn more, check
out the resources listed
in the video
description, including
the Building for
Billions Guidelines
where you will find more
tips for using memory, power,
and network bandwidth more
efficiently in your apps.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]